liam alizés elliott trois orphelins dans
trois pays différents et trois familles
au québec pour qui la pandémie a
prolongé une attente déjà trop longue
on fait parce qu'il vit on n'a pas
nouvelle à partir du moment où on a une
photo de notre enfant que ça allait
ralentir tout le processus pour un très
honnête de décourager quand la pandémie
d'arrivée j'ai eu ce sentiment que ça
durerait plus que deux mois
nous on a envoyé notre premier courriel
à notre agence d'adoption en 2010 avant
le sait coralia et mélodies sont
finalement arrivés au québec en 2017
laissant derrière elle une grande soeur
annie simspon et dan dah guindo qui
voulait réunir la fratrie se préparaient
à partir en haïti quand la pandémie a
mis le monde sur pause et olibeau et
comme j'ai commencé la rage aussi qu'il
faut pas oublier parce que tu es
tellement engagée que que tout ça c'est
pour ça que tu dis que on attend après
ça avant tout des enfants rentrent au
pays
il ya plein de choses qu'on contrôle pas
fixé sur qui on souhaite toujours quels
enfants arrivent le plus rapidement
possible au canada chaque adoption est
une histoire en soi
mon papa est vietnamien donc ça a
toujours été dans mes plans d'adopter au
vietnam est la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler lui l'avait 14 mois donc
voila j'aimerais qu'un petit bout de sa
vie le petit elliot que ludivine lefranc
espérait aller chercher en 2020 à trois
ans et demi maintenant
j'ai toujours pensé qu'être parent
c'était ça c'est et gérer l'imprévu au
quotidien je me fais accompagner par une
psychologue qui m'aide aussi à gérer
cette attente et du jour c'est un petit
peu plus difficile mais globalement je
vous avoue que ça se passe plutôt bien
pendant la pandémie je me suis dit que
c'était peut-être le temps de le faire
donc j'ai fait sa chambre où je vais
régulièrement dans la journée quand j'ai
envie
il a noté que la situation au québec que
la situation dans les pays d'origine
donc on doit essayer de trouver le
moment où les deux pays vont nous
permettre d'aller rencontrer notre
enfant et ça c'est un grand stress tout
ce qui n'est pas en notre pouvoir
les philippines ont fermé le 16 mars
veut plus partir il a fallu attendre
jusqu'à la fin septembre octobre
c'était des billets ouverts alors j'ai
dû partir seul à moins d'une demi heure
on m'a confié cette enfant la fac vous
imaginez le stress pour lui le choc je
comprends pas trop ce qui lui arrive
donc et on doit repartir en avion
anne marie et son conjoint ont adopté
deux enfants aux philippines ont adopté
lauriane ya déjà busan elle était plus
jeune elle avait à peine un an alors que
notre nouveau petit garçon qu'on a
accueilli en octobre avait déjà trois
ans l'adoption internationale est en
déclin
ici transformé dans la dernière décennie
et le portrait des enfants a changé ils
sont plus âgés il ya plus de besoins
spéciaux on est avec des enfants qui ont
pas réussi à être adoptée dans leur pays
d'origine
donc les étrangers sont un peu le
dernier choix pour ces enfants là moi
votre aîné alors que des familles
québécoises adopté près de 1000 enfants
parents au milieu des années 90 ce
nombre a chuté de façon considérable en
il n'y a eu que 139 adoption au cours
des dernières années les pays ont été
sensibilisés à leur capacité ou à leur
devoir de prendre en charge leurs
enfants au sein du même pays
la pandémie est venu ajouter une couche
de complexité à partir du 13 mars
dernier les dossiers d'adoption peu
importe l'étape de réalisation tous
était suspendu la reprise est lente et
inégale selon les pays et les étapes où
se trouvent les familles 337 familles
québécoises sont dans un processus
d'adoption
l'an dernier seulement 61 enfants ont pu
être adopté
les premiers états avec lesquels on est
en mesure de travailler au de finaliser
les démarches d'adoption déjà en cours
sont le burundi et haïti le burundi a
accepté pour ramener les enfants
accompagnés
d'une ex kort burundaise la même chose
pour haïti qui a accepté qu'on ait des
enfants que ce soir accompagné par
escorte
c'est la mère de dan dah guindo qui a
voyagé avec alizée et d'autres enfants
destinés à des familles canadiennes
donc quand ma mère était en haïti puis
elle a dit moi je vais attendre que les
enfants l'inversé mon héros quand les
enfants arrivent c'est vraiment la
récompense de toutes ces années leur
avec mon mari on blague le poids en
papier c'est souvent plus que le poids
de l'enfant à l'arrivée réalisé les plus
vieilles là et vient d'avoir onze ans
donc c'est toute une vie on a utilisé
euros lendemain pouf à montréal dans sa
nouvelle vie mais ça se passe super bien
vraiment mon message à toutes les
parents c'est de ne pas perdre espoir
alors que la chine reste fermé
l'adoption internationale reprend
lentement vietnam j'espère peut-être cet
été on se croise les doigts en attendant
et l'écrit le récit de cette attente que
sa soeur va illustrer pour en faire un
conte pour enfants si anne louise
despatie radio-canada mourir